bonjour notre invité d'aujourd'hui comme
celui de la semaine dernière monsieur
françois bayrou est plus jeune que
monsieur bill clinton
monsieur strauss kahn vous avez 43 ans
vous êtes ministre de l'industrie et du
commerce et vous êtes socialiste
l'actualité de la semaine va nous
fournir la trame de cette heure de
vérité il ya d'abord cette surprenante
sollicitude témoigner par le
gouvernement à nos agriculteurs jeudi
surprenante parce que cela fait bien une
trentaine d'années que les gouvernements
successifs qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche d'ailleurs abandonne les
agriculteurs à leur sort européen pour
le meilleur et pour le pire
fallait-il tombé d'un excédent dans
l'autre est parti en guerre avec autant
de violence contre l'europe et contre
nos partenaires et surtout comment allez
vous vous y prendre maintenant je dis
vous parce que c'est vous le ministre du
gâteau sein du gouvernement
comment allez vous vous y prendre pour
renouer les fils de la négociation alors
nous en parlerons avec alain duhamel
deuxième thème de réflexion la
publication concomitante cette semaine
de deux résultats qui peuvent sembler à
première vue contradictoires dans les
résultats du commerce extérieur qui va
de mieux en mieux et ensuite les
résultats du chômage qui continue hélas
de progresser le gouvernement est en
train de gagner la bataille de la
désinflation compétitive comme on dit
mais à qui qui en profite
vous le dirai à yves messarovitch
rédacteur en chef du figaro économie
enfin nous parlerons de la révision du
procès du militant du milicien paul
touvier et de l'initiative que le
président de la république pourrait
prendre pour prendre ses distances avec
le gouvernement de vichy le paleron si
la convention du parti socialiste qui se
tient en ce moment même à la villette
vous serez au nombre des candidats
désignés ce soir pour partir à la
bataille des élections législatives sous
la bannière de l' alliance pour le
progrès alors vous le dire et de quelles
alliances il s'agit et quel contenu il
faut donner aujourd'hui au mot progrès
depuis que vous êtes laisser dépouiller
par vos adversaires politiques de l'idée
de liberté au moment de la guerre
scolaire de 1984
de l'idée de réforme depuis que monsieur
balladur a fait son dictionnaire et la
rpr sa campagne d'affichage de l'idée de
morale depuis que les affaires et les
scandales se sont enchaînées en fin de
l'idée de justice sociale par le
programme de messieurs pasqua et ce gars
alors que vous reste-t-il c'est quoi
être de gauche dans la france de 1992
on attaque tout de suite les missions
par l'europe avec alain duhamel
bonjour monsieur le ministre
bonjour est ce que vous l'avez lu alors
finalement ce pré accord entre la
commission et le gat dont on disait
qu'il fallait réagir de sur ce sujet
alors que personne n'avait encore reçu
on savait ce qu'il y avait dedans on
sait comment se sont passées
négociations et on en a eu des rapports
parce que la commission a dit aux
différents fonctionnaires des pays mais
il n'y a pas encore de pré accord rédigé
est d'autant moins que pour qu'il y ait
un accord il faut que les politiques le
conseil des ministres donne son
sentiment et on est encore loin du
compte
bon alors qu'est ce que les agriculteurs
français en substance mais pour bien
clarifier les choses dès le début qu'est
ce que les agriculteurs français
risquent de plus que la réforme de la
pac qui déjà les avait fait hurler les
curieux vous poser le problème
uniquement par l'agriculture la sphère
du gatt et loin il m'a semblé qu'on a un
peu parlé l'harmonie on en a beaucoup
parlé mais la sphère du gatt est loin
d'être une affaire qui concerne
uniquement l'agriculture et d'ailleurs
elle est loin d'être une affaire
concerne uniquement la france par
rapport à ses partenaires
c'est en fait un problème qui oppose
l'europe aux états unis et qui concerne
bien d'autres sujets que l'agriculture
concerne les services ça concerne la
contrefaçon ça concerne les marques ça
concerne beaucoup d'autres choses et
l'industrie et je crois que cette
manière de poser la question d'hier
c'est un problème agricole qui oppose
les français aux autres européens
conduits à une analyse qui est erronée
pourquoi est ce qu'en fait c'est un
problème entre l'europe et les états
unis parce que depuis que la négociation
a commencé c'était en 86 les états unis
ont essayé de nous imposer ce qui les
arrange et et eux n'ont parlé que
l'agriculture l'objectif est simple
c'est de démolir ce que l'europe a
construit en matière agricole pour
conquérir une sorte d'armes alimentaire
en étant les seuls à pouvoir vendre des
céréales et d'autres produits agricoles
dans l'ensemble du monde mais nous on a
d'autres objectifs
on a fait pour les en empêcher mais nous
on s'est battus pour les en empêcher on
passe notre temps à dire l'agriculture
c'est bien ça fait dix courses sont à
peu près des échanges reste et 90%
autres et c'est sur ces 90 % autres
qu'on veut se battre et qu'on veut
obtenir des résultats quand vous dites
ce 90% autres qu'on veut se battre ça
veut dire que vous voulez pas vous
battre sur les cultures non ça veut dire
qu'il ne faut pas qu'on se bat
uniquement sur l'agriculture et l'on
rate vous aurions tort de considérer
qu'il s'agit que d'un projet d'annexion
mais pour être direct sincère 20
commandes nettes à cette émission vous
êtes quand même d'accord que le débat
cette semaine a largement porté sur
l'agriculture et que quand on écoute et
votre premier ministre de deux choses
l'une ou bien vous êtes en désaccord si
j'en crois ce que vous venez de dire ou
bien alors vous lui aviez pas expliqué
avant non le premier ministre connaît
très bien ses affaires et je suis en
plein désaccord avec lui il a parlé
beaucoup de l'agriculture comme il
nommait on est au point de la
négociation ou c'est l'agriculture qui
sur la table alors qui est bien normal
qu'on s'en occupe bon mais ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que la présentation
que je lis un peu partout que j'ai
entendu aussi dire par de bons esprits
dont vous je crois monsieur duhamel à
savoir que ce problème était
fondamentalement un problème agricole
est je crois une présentation qui est
erroné quand quand les agf ne peuvent
pas s'installer dans l'état de new york
parce qu'on dit vous êtes une entreprise
à capital public dont vous n'avez pas le
droit de venir ça c'est un problème de
gat et c'est un problème qui est aussi
important que le problème agricole
d'accord alors la caisse tout je vous
avais posé à laquelle selon toutes les
règles vous n'avez pas répondu mais ça
ça prouve que vous étiez fait pour cette
émission
l'action vous avez posé ses caisses que
le pré accord auquel on est parvenu à
porte comme vrai risque supplémentaire
pour les agriculteurs français
alors quelle est votre réponse alors
nous avons réformer la politique
agricole commune au printemps
et contrairement à ce que dit
l'opposition nous avons bien fait de
faire les choses dans cet ordre là parce
que l'ayant réformes et nous savons
maintenant jusqu'où nous pouvons aller
et ce que nous ne pouvons pas accepter
le pré accord tel qu'on le connaît
implique des conséquences qui vont au
delà de cette réforme la prière école
commune par exemple en substance sur
exemple sur les céréales par exemple sur
la viande bovine par exemple sur les
produits laitiers
tout donne à penser les calculs que nous
faisons musée la france nous c'est la
france mais c'est pas seulement la
france c'est aussi les espagnols c'est
aussi les belges eux c'est un peu les
italiens c'est pas mal les portugais lui
si on accepte cet accord les entend cela
tandis que si on accepte cet accord
alors les conséquences sur l'agriculture
seront des conséquences qui vont au-delà
de ce que les uns et les autres avons
mis en place en terme de respect
l'appétit agricole commune et c'est pour
ça que nous ne pouvons pas accepter
bon est ce que vous considérez que la
commission qui était comme c'est
d'ailleurs son rôle chargée de négocier
l'a fait de façon équitable et l'a fait
en tenant compte des intérêts des
agriculteurs français italien espagnol
portugais danois etc je crois que les
négociateurs ont fait de leur mieux mais
je crois que ce mieux n'est pas un
résultat acceptable et par conséquent il
faudra que d'une manière ou d'une autre
ce qui se mettra en oeuvre sur la partie
agricole du gatt ne soient pas ceux qui
résultent de ces d'accord ou de ce pré
accord de washington est ce que les
choses ont la moindre chance de se
passer convenablement temps qu'une
présidence britannique
ça fait six ans qu'on en débat et
présidence ne dure que six mois donc
dans cannes donc dans votre esprit les
britanniques qui ont bien joué le jeu là
elles sont comportés comme il le devait
dans cette phase de négociation rappelle
que c'est la commission qui négocie et
pas la présidence si bien qu'un
événement c'était pas évident il ya des
monospaces britannique est allergique à
l'agriculture verrait très bien vous
avez raison mais il reste que c'est la
commission qui négocie et le conseil des
ministres dans son ensemble qui prendra
une décision
bon alors maintenant est ce qu on est
isolé ou pas isolé ça dépend comment
vers la question je vous disais à
l'instant les portugais et espagnols les
belges d'autres encore sont sur des
positions qui sont pas loin de les noter
d'ailleurs le 10/10 nous position nous
partageons assez la position de la
france ils disent des choses de gens là
mais à l inverse il est vrai que laveran
la france est au premier plan
elle est un peu le chef de file de ceux
qui se battent et d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas la première fois dans l'histoire la
construction européenne que la france
est plus ferme plus volontaire qu'un
certain nombre d'autres pays il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui disent ce
qu'il faudrait se serait pouvoir
réouvrir les négociations avec les
américains est ce que c'est pas de
l'utopie absolue sans nom je crois pas
que ce soit d'utopie je ne sais pas si
c'est ce qui se fera de toute façon la
négociation elle n'est pas fermée
puisqu'elle doit continuer sur bien
d'autres aspects si la france est amenée
d'une manière ou d'une autre à voter sur
ce qui lui est proposé aujourd'hui elle
votera contre
mais j'ai bon espoir qu'on s'en sorte
autres membres autrement dit vous avez
bon espoir qu'on n'en arrive pas là j'ai
bon espoir qu'on n'en arrive pas là et
que nos partenaires comprennent qu'ils
n'ont pas intérêt à nous amener là vous
savez la solidarité dans la construction
européenne elle a existé à plusieurs
reprises nous l'avons eu
pour les allemands lorsque les nouveaux
länder ont été associés à la rfa et
qu'il a fallu faire des efforts nous
l'avons eue à l'égard des anglais
lorsqu'ils ont souhaité un air de
politique sociale
avoir un rôle d'une situation
particulière aujourd'hui il faut que
cette solidarité joue en faveur des
spécificités de l'agriculture française
et je pense que nos partenaires peuvent
le comprendre qu'est ce qu'on peut leur
demander comment est-ce que ça peut se
passer
c'est l'objet des réunions qui vont se
tenir à partir dans une semaine
oui il ya deux voies possibles la
première voit c'est que tout le monde
considère assez grand nombre considère
qu'en effet cet accord n'est pas
satisfaisant et que par conséquent on
retourne négocier les américains et moi
je n'accepte pas l'idée qu'a priori un
diktat américain ne puisse pas être
repoussée est ce qu'on appelle peut
appeler ça un diktat à partir du moment
où il ya eu un pré accord avec la
commission nommés après accord de la
part de la commission qui négocient
encore une fois pas de la part des
politiques qui sont là pour décider seul
et les américains l année là la
commission elle négocie avec un mandat
cruel négocié avec un mandat et on peut
penser c'est tout l'objet des calculs
qui sont en cours qu'elle a outrepassé
son mandat c'est bien le débat si elle a
outrepassé son mandat il faudra
renégocier
bon donc l'hypothèse selon laquelle on
recommencerait négociations entre
européens et américains ça ne vous
paraît pas a priori un peu irréaliste
menaçable par ed ottoman et réalise
qu'il faut la conduire sur d'autres
choses
moi je suis miss de l'industrie j'ai
beaucoup de domaine dans lequel je veux
passer de nouveaux accords au sein du
cat je veux permettre aux industries
françaises par exemple télécom de
pouvoir s'établir sur des marchés
américains qui aujourd'hui leur sont
fermés je veux pouvoir lutter contre la
contrefaçon matières textiles qui est un
domaine dans lequel il faut encore
négocier et il faut aboutir
et dans ces conditions la négociation
est loin d'être terminée donc que sur la
partie agricole ont soit amené à y
revenir ne paraît pas du tout impossible
bon et alors si puisqu'on va rencontrer
nos partenaires pour le coup on va leur
demander des compensations ou des
dérogations ou des aides qu'est ce qu'on
va leur demander exactement qu'est ce
qu'on peut vraiment espérer obtenir
nous on leur demandera des compensations
des choses de ce genre là que le jour où
on sera d'accord sur ce qui oppose les
états unis
à l'europe et à l'arasement là on
s'arrangera entre européens mais encore
une fois aujourd'hui nous en sommes
toujours à la partie bras de fer qui est
normal entre deux grandes puissances
commerciales entre l'europe et les états
unis les états unis voyez-vous ont
échoué dans leur guerre commerciale
contre l'asie contre le japon contre
l'accord il n'arrive pas à pénétrer ces
marchés il essaye de reporter ce qu'ils
n'ont pas réussi à faire sur l'asie vers
l'europe mais l'europe n'a aucune raison
de se laisser faire elle a aucune raison
de se laisser faire et moi qui suis un
très chaud partisan de la construction
européenne comme d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'autres je ne veux pas d'une europe
vassal je vais d'une europe qui se
construit éventuellement en s'opposant
est ce que le veto qui ont brandi
toujours comme l' arme ultime est ce que
le veto ça n'est pas en réalité un sabre
de bois c'est à dire que pour qu'on
puisse l'utiliser il faut qu'ils aient
un texte écrit en forme juridique et que
le moment où ne l'utiliserai ce texte il
y aura une pression formidable des 107
autres pays qui sont parties à la
négociation
ce qui fait que ça on pourrait toujours
crié je suis n'est pas un sabre de bois
je suis plutôt à la dissuasion nucléaire
il faut essayer en l'ayant de ne pas
avoir besoin de s'en servir et votre
pronostic et qu'on n'aura pas besoin de
s'en servir ou politique c'est qu'on
n'aura pas besoin de s'en servir parce
que mon pronostic c'est que l'europe
sera se ressaisir et s'opposer à une
volonté américaine nous sortir du marché
est ce que parce que vous savez que les
américains qui prétendent que nous
subventionnons trop qu'il faut tuer
notre agriculture etc occupent
aujourd'hui près de 50% du marché
mondial des céréales et nous 13%
mais il considère que ce n'est pas assez
qui va nous sortir du marché et
conquérir cette arme alimentaire dont je
parlais tout à l'heure c'est contre ça
que nous battons eh bien ça il ya aucune
raison que nos partenaires là nous
rejoignent palette la prochaine étape
qui va avoir lieu ça va être le sommet
franco germanique la semaine prochaine
dans ce sommet ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut au départ être confiant dans la
solidarité des allemands qui vont être
déterminants dans cette histoire j'ai
entendu déclaration du chancelier kohl
qui ne m'ont pas déplu et jusqu'à
maintenant la solidarité entre la france
et l'allemagne n'a jamais failli donc
moi je crois qu'en effet ce sommet là
qui vient très opportunément avant que
les négociations reprennent viendra
éclaircir le paysage
en tout état de cause si comme je le
disais tout à l'heure nous souhaitons
faire en sorte que les choses se passent
de façon douce et solidaire nous ne
renoncerons aucune manière à
l'utilisation éventuelle du veto dont a
parlé le premier ministre monsieur son
scan si on refait une émission avec vous
dans un an ce qui devait pas que tu es
ce que vous pensez qu'il ya toujours un
système monétaire européen
je vais vous répondre oui et je vais
vous répondre que je le regrette parce
que ce que je voudrais c'est qu'on aille
le plus vite possible vers l'union
monétaire telle qu'elle est décrite par
un traité de maastricht alors un an
c'était un peu court mais ce que je
pense c'est que un des éléments de cette
construction européenne forte justement
c'est la construction d'union monétaire
si bien que plus on ira vite plus on
brûlera les étapes
plus nous serons dans une situation qui
évitera de connaître les crises qu'on a
vu il ya quelques semaines contre la
lire italienne contre la livre anglaise
que ce qui est en train de se passer ce
n'est pas au contraire une
désintégration du système monétaire
européen
donc voilà livre qui est en dehors quand
on voit la lyre l'escudo serra est ce
que la pente n'est pas à la
désintégration et non pas à la
convergence non il ya eu il ya eu des
périodes dans le passé de difficultés de
même nature il ya eu des périodes de
crise crois pas qu'il faille y voir la
construction européenne comme quelque
chose de doux une sorte de carsan
assurez-vous transversale 50 sa crise
c'est une succession de crises sur
différents domaines alors les
commerciales et monétaires mais chaque
fois on l'a surpassé on construira
l'europe dans le fait de surpasser
justement s'écrit donc votre pronostic
c'est que le système monétaire européen
avant qu on en passe on passe à l'union
monétaire que le système monétaire
européen peut tenir et viable tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui
je crois plus et monétaires a été conçu
comme les choses qui étaient par nature
transitoire avant d'en venir à cette
union monétaire qu'il a des difficultés
qui sont assez grandes par exemple liés
aux taux d'intérêt
trop élevés qui sont liées aussi aux
fluctuations du dollar et que une des
meilleures manières de lutter contre ces
difficultés là c'est de forcer les feux
pour aller vers l'union et ça c'est ce
qu'est ce qui pourrait être bien en
théorie est ce qu en pratique c'est
possible est-ce que ce à quoi on assiste
dans ce moment ce n'est pas justement à
une divergence des situations
économiques des politiques économiques
mais là le rôle des hommes politiques le
rôle de ceux qui veulent construire
l'europe c'est de faire que ce qui est
possible se fasse et puisque c'est
possible il faut aller dans ce sens-là
moi je veux une europe qui soit une
europe forte qui c'est une europe qui
s'opposent aux autres si c'est
nécessaire est un des moyens de le faire
c'est justement cette construction
monétaire
donc quand vous me dites nous sommes en
situation difficile le système monétaire
européen est chahuté tous les côtés
c'est vrai c'est vrai les visuels dans
le contre c'est vrai mais le moyen
d'éviter que nous restions en situation
instable c'est pas de trouver
l'équilibré vers le bas c'est tout un
équilibre vers le haut et équilibre vers
le haut c'est l'union monétaire est-ce
que l'union monétaire ne peut se faire
qu'avec ceux qui sont capables de la
faire vibrer tous les pays ne sont pas
forcément capable de la faire en même
temps est-ce que l'hypothèse qui circule
beaucoup selon laquelle il y aurait des
initiatives et qu'on commencerait à
accélérer justement comme vous le disiez
à l'instant les échéances mais non pas
au niveau global mais avec les pays
qu'ils peuvent avec l'allemagne avec le
benelux peut être avec le danemark en
tout cas avec la france est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous paraît
vraisemblable c'est un débat qui est
ouvert en tout cas le fait de savoir si
dans la mesure où on voudra avancé il
faudra avancer avec certains seulement
avec d'autres ensuite c'est un débat qui
est ouvert est justement c'est ce débat
là la solution à ce débat là qui
remettra de savoir quels sont les délais
ce qui est sûr en tout sera temps à
mesure que les discussions se fera et
que lors la discussion se fera quand la
discussion et existe maintenant où
s'achèvera qu'en mon nom mais je ne veux
pas fuir une question la discussion
existe vous la voulez vous la posez vous
même vous dit le système monétaire est
chahuté qu'est ce qu'on va faire
la manière dont l'ensemble des économies
peuvent discuter de savoir si elles
veulent avancer celles qui le peuvent
avancer en se réunissant les autres sur
suivant derrière et justement au centre
du débat aujourd'hui mais je crois pour
ma part que c'est la voie à ce que
l'union européenne qui a quand même
occuper largement le premier semestre de
cette année
n'est pas mort n'est aujourd'hui non je
crois pas je crois pas assez c'est le
retour sur votre question initiale si on
croit que le problème qui nous oppose
aux états unis est en fait un problème
intra-européen alors on peut se dire on
a beaucoup voulu parler d'europe en
septembre par exemple pour du référendum
en france puis aujourd'hui on voit que
les choses se délitent
mais si on conçoit autrement qu'en fait
tout ça c'est une manière pour l'europe
d'exister et que existé ça consiste à ne
pas passer sous la table à la première
algarade avec les états unis
alors je crois que la situation que nous
vivons aujourd'hui renforce au contraire
la nécessité de ce qu'on a voulu
construire avec notre argent que vous
pensez que en ce moment les l'évolution
de la grande bretagne depuis quelques
mois va dans le sens d'une accélération
de sa ratification à maastricht non je
crois et je regrette que l'association
anglaise soit celle là je crois que ça
prendra du temps pour arriver à
ratification par les anglais mais je
vous croyais qu'ils y arriveront je
crois qu'on y arrivera je crois qu'on y
arrivera l'année prochaine j'en suis le
premier ministre monsieur mais ce genre
a annoncé de délais que je crois bien
lourd regrette qu'il soit aussi long
mais ça c'est ce leurs problèmes
je crois en tout cas qu'on y arrivera en
effet mais encore une fois on a d'autant
plus besoin d'y arriver que les
problèmes de la france c'est vrai pour
les autres pays aussi mais les problèmes
de la france face au reste du monde
d'aujourd'hui sont bien des problèmes
européens et pas des problèmes isolés de
tel ou tel pays
une dernière question quand on regarde
ce qui vient de passer se passer au
cours de la négociation entre l'europe
et le gâte quand on voit ce qui se passe
à propos du système monétaire européen
quand on voit les délais en ce qui
concerne la ratification de maastricht
qu'est ce qui va bien en europe en ce
moment c'est l'europe et constitue un
somme de pays qui chacun à leur moment
dans l'histoire en dominer le monde
c'est vrai des français les espagnols
les portugais même des grecs c'est vrai
des anglais etc et on tente ensemble de
faire ce qui s'est jamais fait dans
l'histoire c'est à dire de réunir ces
pays non pas par la force par la volonté
démocratique c'est tenait à des moments
ce soit difficile est un peu naïf c'est
évidemment très difficile
c'est très difficile c'est l'expérience
qui n'a jamais été tentée qui de mon
point de vue est en train de réussir
même si à des moments qui sont qui sont
pénibles mais ce qui va bien c'est que
finalement chacun comme la volonté
d'avancer joue si c'est tout à l'heure
ce qu'on a fait pour les länder
allemands quand les allemands sont venus
taper à la porte sans nous avons besoin
de votre solidarité
ils l'ont trouvée eh bien je suis sûr
que la récré on aura la réciproque
exactement merci alain duhamel alors on
enchaîne maintenant
yves messarovitch rédacteur en chef du
figaro économie et ancien élève du
professeur strauss kahn bonjour monsieur
le ministre
bonjour professeurs se sont ce sont les
cheveux blancs qui font que finalement
on finit par retrouver de ses élèves
dans des fonctions importantes
c'était il n'ya pas si longtemps une
première question si vous le permettez
concernant la vente de mirage à taïwan
je n'ai toujours pas compris si on les
avait vendues ou pas les américains qui
ont vendu 150 nous 60 n'ont pas les
mêmes pudeurs presse que ces signes ou
pas c'est pékin qui nous dit que ceux-ci
du gouvernement français n'a eu à
approuver aucun accord en ce sens et
d'entreprises ont été autorisés à
négocier je n'ai connaissance d'aucun
accord n'en serons pas plus aujourd'hui
bien questions plus générales sur
l'économie française vous lisez la
presse tous les jours il ya en fait deux
diagnostic sur la situation actuelle
il ya celles que nous livre les
statistiques officielles l'insee qui
disent qu'en moyenne les comiques
français se porte plutôt bien
elle se porte même mieux d'ailleurs que
ses partenaires européens voient leurs
connexions le souligner c'est exact mais
n'en parlera tout à l'heure mais aussi
le diagnostic au roucas sur le terrain
qu'est celui de chef d'entreprise qui le
dit c'est plus possible on passe plus la
rampe
on va tout droit vers une situation
semblable à celle des années 30 alors
qui dit la vérité
un peu les deux un peu les deux la
france situation économique est plutôt
meilleure que celle de ses voisins ça
c'est clair
à part le japon n'y a pas de taux de
croissance supérieur au nôtre même s'ils
n'ont d'autre faible notre inflation
chacun la connaît est maintenant très en
dessous de celle de nos voisins à qui
aurait dit ça ya une dizaine d'années
quand même et notre commerce extérieur
que françois henri de virieu salué tout
à l'heure donc me remercie aussi est
revenu de façon je crois assez stable
pour un assez grand nombre d'années dans
une situation excédentaire là aussi qui
aurait dit ça ya dix ans donc
globalement notre économie française va
en effet quand mais la question que
soulève la question c'est pas espoir on
n'est pas en train de mourir guéri
maintenant ça ça c'est une formule
amusante mais on meurt jamais guéri
quand on est guéri on est guéri le
problème c'est que il ya un stand de
secteur et qui vivent mal la situation
actuelle parce que globalement la
croissance est trop faible
et ça c'est vrai et donc il est facile -
je rencontre dans mon bureau de mise de
l'industrie régulièrement déchets
entreprises qui viennent me voir en me
disant là ça m'a pas on va être obligé
de fermer et il ya des secteurs qui sont
très sinistré ça c'est vrai aussi
autrement dit l'économie française et
assez largement guéri et en ce sens elle
est aujourd'hui une des plus puissants
une des plus restructurer une des plus
renforcée de l'ensemble de la planète
mais comme l'ensemble de la croissance
mondiale est aujourd'hui beaucoup trop
faible je pense qu'on va y revenir tout
à l'heure la situation même ans comme a
dit monsieur sap à votre place il ya
quinze jours on a la plus belle voilure
du monde mais y'a pas devant une belle
expression
cela dit il ya des grandes entreprises
qui se portent très bien ce sont celles
qui sont d'ailleurs sous votre tutelle
pour nous rendre parti il ya le monde
des pme qui sont souvent sous traitante
de ces entreprises est qui qui ne
comprennent plus la situation ils sont
ils ont des bons produits
les banquiers n'ont rien à leur
reprocher gèrent bien leur entreprise me
mettre la clé sous la porte à cause des
taux d'intérêt notamment s'adonner à
cause d'une croissance d'ensemble qui
leur fait mais c'est pour ça que
l'initiative qui a été avancée par
plusieurs notamment par jacques delors
prises en france qui est tout à l'heure
sur la volonté mettre en place
initiative européenne de croissance
c'est-à-dire par des grands projets
d'infrastructure relancer la croissance
en europe et d'initiatives qui est
absolument indispensable parce que la
voilure que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
est en place les grands groupes français
vous en disiez un hameau sont maintenant
redresser
qui aurait dit qu'ils auraient dit à
cinq ou six ans que usinor serait la
seconde entreprise sidérurgique au monde
après les japonais plus forte que
british style plus forte que les
allemands plus forte que les belges on
n'aurait pas donné un centime de cette
entreprise là aujourd'hui usine aurait
là je prends cet exemple on pourra en
prendre plein d'autres regarder la
situation de renault
nous avons donc dans le secteur public
mais aussi d'un secteur privé des
entreprises qui ont retrouvé leur
puissance et c'est vrai que le marché
fait défaut alors si un rôle à remplir
c'est de recréer ce marché et notamment
au niveau européen on vous dit les
grandes entreprises se portent mieux
je vous donne un exemple pechiney par
exemple est une entreprise publique
annoncée pour la semaine prochaine un
programme de restructuration qui va se
traduire par un certain nombre de
centaines d'emplois air france est
également dans la même situation ils ont
4 milliards de pertes cette année
l'année prochaine ils en auront moins
mise en auront encore là aussi les
suppressions d'emplois importantes à
régler
alors ma question est celle-ci il y a au
delà de la situation macroéconomique un
certain nombre de bombes à retardement
si je puis dire qu'ils n'ont pas été
réglés notamment en matière de chômage
alors jusqu'où d'après vous les grandes
entreprises publiques vont peut-être
pouvoir continuer à supprimer des
emplois ne veut pas que le chômage d'une
bombe à retardement le chômage on peut
le regarder d'un point de vue
statistiques on peut aussi le regarder
autrement et tous ceux qui sont des élus
dans des villes et circonscription
savent que ça une réalité plus concrètes
plus sociale moi je suis l'élu de la
banlieue parisienne une large partie de
la population avec laquelle je travaille
qui est au chômage et c'est pas un prof
de statistiques globales s'apprennent
concret j'ai une fille qui à 19 ans il
doit se retrouver au chômage dans un ou
deux ans c'est pour moi un problème qui
dépasse très largement un problème
d'ensemble d'ap récession macroeconomic
maintenant c'est vrai aussi que nous
avons cette donnée là
jusqu'à quand les grandes entreprises
devaient le faire cela vous savez nous
avons en france une particularité qui
est que nous attachons plus que d'autres
du prix au remplacement du travail de
l'homme par le travail de la machine
monde le fait c'est le progrès technique
qui s'incorpore des entreprises mais
plus que d'autres et il ya très nombreux
exemples qui montrent qu'on aurait pu
faire autrement je vous en cite justin
pour illustrer cela nous avons développé
beaucoup plus que d'autres
les pompes à essence automatique c'est
pas obligatoirement très pratique
maintenant je prendre de l'essence je
suis pas obligatoirement ravi de devoir
me servir moi-même et de menottes de
l'essence sur les pieds il reste que
nous ont fait beaucoup plus que d'autres
parce qu'en france la machine c'est
moderne et si c'est moderne c'est bien
beaucoup plus que chez nos voisins
la conséquence c'est qu' à 30000 emplois
dans ce petit exemple des pompes à
essence qui aurait pu être préservée et
on peut trouver des tas d'autres
exemples comme ça partout dans le monde
le fait d'avoir des gardiens d'immeuble
est considéré comme un luxe et comme un
plus en france on les a tous supprimés
pour mettre des visiophone des iphone
autrement dit la société française à
cette difficulté particulière que s'il
faut un temps d'incorporer la technique
ça tout le monde est d'accord il faut
essayer de l'incorporer sans aller
au-delà de ce qui est nécessaire et cela
dans un son de l'entreprise sont deux
secteurs on ne le fait pas la
conséquence c'est qu'on a un nombre de
chômeurs parfois si vous servir on peut
par complètement passée par pertes et
profits les statistiques
est-ce que vous pensez que monsieur
bérégovoy a raison de dire que nous ne
franchirons pas le cap des trois
millions de chômeurs avant les élections
législatives
on y est on y est on frôle les 3
millions 5 octobre 3 millions
dix mille chômeurs or il n'ya pas de
chômeurs cvs n'existe pas dans la rue il
ya des chômeurs brut donc la barre des
30 des 3 millions et et comment il
fallait faire un combat de chiffre
symbolique c'est au tour si des
objectifs c'est normal le problème est
de savoir vraiment si on franchit aussi
on franchit pas cette barre le prétoire
ce qu'on fait pour essayer de lutter
contre et le programme quel point les
mines sa lancée par exemple sur les
chômeurs de longue durée il a raison de
s'attaquer à ces deux catégories des
chômeurs tout particulièrement est un
programme qui s'il ne résout pas tous
les problèmes a donné un stand le succès
déjà vous avez vu que la durée du
chômage a baissé d'une vingtaine de
jours vous avez vu que ce nombre de
chômeurs de grande durée est en train
lentement c'est vrai mais est en train
de décroître et c'est ça qui compte
c'est le trait mais qu'elle vous qui
avait dit aussi au moment où vous êtes
arrivés au pouvoir nous allons réduire
le chômage et vous avez donné des
chiffres pense à 80 je pense que vous
avez raison on avait on avait fixé comme
objectif premier de réduire le chômage
et on a trouvé une société notamment une
économie qui avait suffisamment besoin
d'être remis sur pied pour que ce soit
possible tout de suite et que les gens
nous le reproche aujourd'hui me paraît
normal ça me paraît normal on leur avait
annoncé qu'on fait quelque chose on n'a
pas réussi à le faire
on a fait ce qu'il fallait faire pour
pouvoir finalement redresser les choses
mais on n'a pas réussi à atteindre ces
objectifs là c'est normal qu'on nous
reproche mais si on n'était pas passé
par là 12 ans si on n'était pas passé
par là ce n'est pas redresser les
entreprises le commerce extérieur
l'inflation comme on l'a fait l'économie
française on aurait crevé et aujourd'hui
on n'en serait pas à dire est ce qu'on
va passer ou pas à la barrette revient
aux chômeurs on serait malheureusement
sans doute bien au delà donc on
reconnaissait qu'il y a quand même un
paradoxe en 82 on nationalise est pour
créer des emplois
en 92 on a recours aux privatisations
partielles pour financer le chômage
c'est plus qu'un revirement idéologique
qui s'est vraiment passé quelque chose
entre que les français n'ont pas compris
mais d'abord il s'est passé entre je
l'évoquerai reproduisit nord au renault
que les entreprises publiques en
question ont été redressés ont été
redressés et aujourd'hui comment par qui
regardez renault dans les entreprises où
air france est évident que ce n'est pas
encore fait ils paient les entreprises
pour lesquelles leur relation ne soit
pas fait mais le nombre d'entreprises
publiques qui ont été redressés est
considérable
or que maintenant on se pose la question
de savoir si dans les dix ans qui
viennent il faut conserver un secteur
public qui a la même taille ou plus
faible c'est une bonne question moi je
crois que la france a besoin d'un
secteur public et je crois que la
volonté de tout privatiser que je
constate à droite est absurde maintenant
il faut avoir les critères sur lesquels
on veut conserver quelque chose dans le
secteur public et ces critères là ils
sont vos mois relativement simple par
exemple tous les domaines à grand risque
dans lesquels on ne voit pas le
capitalisme privé à investir
suffisamment moi j'ai fait en sorte
depuis un an que dans les composants
électroniques qui seront la base de
toute l'industrie dans les années qui
viennent nous ayons une production
européenne
et si possible française l'accord passé
avec les italiens qui a été annoncé
récemment vous l'avez vu et un accord
qui va permettre cela si faune sonne
exactement dans un geste en ce sens il
faut que l'état son équipe s'il faut que
l'état intervienne c'est tout simplement
parce que le marché ne le fait pas si le
marché le faisait il n'y a pas besoin de
l'état mais le marché ne le fait pas
alors ces sables où on le fait à l'aide
de capitaux publics où on ne le fait pas
et si on ne le fait pas il y aura plus
d'industries européennes
en tout cas plus l'industrie française
dans dix ans dans une voiture
aujourd'hui il ya 15 % de composants
électroniques dans dix ans donnera 25%
si on est obligé de les acheter à
l'étranger on n'aura pas le dernier
modèle on les paiera plus cher on sera
pas livrée dans les délais on sera plus
capable de faire ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que la clio la r19 la
205 seconde en allemagne comme elles se
vendent alors qu'on a besoin d'eux fera
et seul l'état celle l'état dans un pays
comme le nôtre est capable de le faire
pour cela il faut de l'argent il faut de
l'argent vous n'en avez plus et ça
m'amène la deuxième bombe à retardement
dont je parlais tout à l'heure c'est la
dette savait que la dette a beaucoup
augmenté durant douze ans elle a été
mutilée par simple je crois même
davantage les deux déficits budgétaires
successives 91 pardon 92 93 on alourdir
encore de 400 milliards
ça fait autant autant de moins si je
puis dire d'argent disponible pour les
dotations en capital
jusqu'où pourrez vous laisser filer le
déficit et la dette
voilà monsieur mais sa revue
transformant un harpagon non je lis le
chiffrant les entreprises ont commencé à
se développer au 19e siècle et encore
plus au xxème siècle quand le crédit
bancaire leur a permis d'emprunter pour
investir
l'emprunt n'est pas en soi quelque chose
de critiquable il faut pas emprunter
plus qu'on en a besoin et surtout plus
qu'on ne pourra rembourser mais croire
que parce qu'il ya une dette publique
l'état se porte mal tu as manqué
évidemment et simpliste
alors on peut se poser la question de
savoir si on l'a trop de déficit on n'a
pas trop de déficit ça c'est vrai mais
en soit le fait de devoir emprunter
c'est ce que font toutes les entreprises
pour se développer si elle ne le faisait
pas n'existerait plus pourquoi est-ce
que ce qui est vrai pour les entreprises
ne seraient pas vrai pour les cas c'est
vrai pour l'état aussi il faut être
capable de mesurer cet endettement ne
pas aller au delà de ce qui est
raisonnable c'est vrai aussi pour tout
un chacun qui achètent une maison il
faut être capable de mesurer à leur
mesure on est ce que nous avons un
déficit exagéré par rapport à notre
économie par rapport à nos voisins
vous savez bien que non ça allait très
bien nous avons un déficit budgétaire
qui s'il est plus important aujourd'hui
qu'il n'a été ya un an parce qu'il faut
soutenir l'activité économique reste
inférieur à celui de la plupart de nos
voisins c'est les fameux critères de
convergence qui permettent de construire
l'union monétaire chère à alain duhamel
donc ceux qui la bonne question c'est
est-ce que nous nous endettons trop et
là je réponds non ceux qui la mauvaise
question et que pose l'opposition tous
les jours c'est de dire ah là là nous
avons des dettes mais toutes les
entreprises qui vont bien ont des dettes
et de ce point de vue le fonctionnement
de l'état n'est pas différent deux
observations sur la dette si vous le
permettez 2000 milliards de dette
publique
le cap est franchi et ça va continuer
donc l'année prochaine ça coûte très
cher en taux d'intérêt parce que ça
fonctionne les marchés financiers donc
c'est de l'argent moins cher de
disponible c'est moins d'argent moins
cher disponibles sur les marchés y
compris pour les particuliers et
deuxièmement c'est quand même une façon
d'hypothéquer si je puis dire les
générations futures parce qu'il faudra
bien la rembourser au moins en partie
et dans quelques mais non ça n'est pas
hypothéqué générations futures ce qui
serait hypothéqué générations futures
c'est de refuser d'avoir un déficit
raisonnable et en contrepartie de
refuser de construire les écoles les
hôpitaux dont nous avons besoin ça c'est
hypothéquer les générations futures mais
nous prendre l'argent qui est nécessaire
pour la formation pour la sécurité
sociale à différents endroits du système
de l' organisation de la société
c'est tout le contraire d'hypothéquer
les générations futures la reconnaissez
que de toute façon ça freine quand même
la baisse possible des taux d'intérêt en
france
par ailleurs et c'est même une question
sur l'allemagne dont parlait
duhamel tout à l'heure on sait très bien
que les allemands ne veulent pas baisser
les taux d'intérêts nous sommes pris
dans un étau aussi bien le point de vue
interne en raison du poids de la dette
que d'un point de vue externe du fait de
notre relation avec l'allemagne
est ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
quand même qu'on est dans un piège dont
on n'arrive plus à sortir on a une
difficulté on a une difficulté qui est
que notre volonté partagée d'ailleurs
avec un son de nos partenaires de
construire l'europe fait qu' on est un
peu dans l'entre-deux on peut plus faire
tout ce qu'on veut chez nous parce que
les économies sont beaucoup plus
interpénétrés qu'elle l'était dans le
passé et on n'est pas encore au tour
d'une table à partager ensemble la
souveraineté qui consisterait à décider
ensemble des taux d'intérêt on est dans
un entre deux et c'est pour ça que je
disais tout à l'heure qu'il faut aller
le plus vite possible vers la phase
supérieure la phase on sera tous autour
d'une table avec les allemands avec les
anglais avec les belges a décidé
ensemble les taux d'intérêt plutôt que
de voir les allemands les décider sans
nous et dans une certaine mesure nous
d'être obligé de suivre
je constate quand même que depuis
quelques temps les taux intéressants
sont plutôt à la baisse
et vous avez quand même raison ils sont
trop élevés et la voix pour échapper à
ça c'est bien sûr une monnaie qui sera
une monnaie européenne c'est pour ça
qu'il faut aller plus vite la
construction européenne premier que les
allemands sont d'accord avec vous ils
l'ont accepté c'est d'ailleurs c'était
avant la réunification
ç'a changé depuis un an les allemands
ont fait un don une offrande à la
construction européenne formidable en
acceptant justement que ce qui était
leur arme principale le deutschmark
devienne quelque chose qui soit partagée
avec les autres
nous avons aussi des efforts à faire
chacun veut faire de son côté des formes
l'effort allemand il est clair et ils
l'ont accepté et à aucun moment les
sentiments qui leur viennent et où on
leur donnera quoi en échange nous nous
avons un stand de difficultés dans la
construction européenne vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la pâte
c'était peut-être alain duhamel en dix
ans nous avons fait cette réforme de la
pac au printemps dernier elle est
difficile pour nos agriculteurs
oui elle est difficile pour nos
agriculteurs nous avons fait en sorte
qu'elle soit la moins douloureuse
possible
nous avons mis en échange en place des
compensations il reste qu elle est
douloureuse pour nos agriculteurs et
c'est un effort que la france a accepté
pour participer à la solidarité
européenne
dernière question prospectives supposent
on vous gagner les élections de 93
qu'est ce que vous allez peut-être qu
est ce que vous envisagez
comme mesure que vous n'ayez pas pu
prendre à la date d'aujourd'hui est
question si vous prenez ces telle ou
telle mesure pourquoi ne pas la prendre
dès maintenant je crois qu'il ya
plusieurs pistes dans lesquels il faudra
qu'on a quand on aura gagné les
élections il faudra qu'on n'aille plus
fort qu on a été jusqu'à maintenant
d'abord il ya tout ce qui concerne le
partage du travail c'est un thème qui a
eu mauvaise presse par un nombre
d'années que nous avons trop laissé de
côté on avait commencé en 82 et puis on
a trop laissé de côté
chacun comprend bien pourtant que quand
il ya des progrès techniques il faut
bien d'une manière ou d'une autre que le
temps de travail diminue ça c'est fait
depuis un siècle pour ça continue avec
réduction du salaire depuis un siècle
l'introduction du progrès technique a
fait qu'on a travaillé sur l'ensemble de
la vie moins qu'avant plus de retraite
plus d'études durée hebdomadaire qui
diminue et c'est ça il faudra avancer
il faudra aussi qu'on avance
considérablement sur les banlieues les
banlieues on s'en est beaucoup
préoccuper sa problème à ces nouveaux
qui a émergé on n'a pas encore fait
l'effort nécessaire sur le temps de
transport qu'il faut pour aller de paris
à la banlieue parisienne par exemple
pour travailler tous les matins ou
rentrer tous les soirs là il ya des
efforts à faire qu'on n'a pas su faire
encore suffisamment ça fait des éléments
de programme vous ne laissez pas le
temps visiblement avaient ou non on va
s'arrêter là il veut messarovitch
mercier on enchaîne avec jean marie
colombani mais vous pouvez continuer
votre pensée sur les villes à ce qu'il
est vraiment nécessaire de continuer à
grandir les villes comme on le fait
actuellement a ajouté la banlieue à la
banlieue éternellement
c'est un problème qui est posé jean
marie colombani c'est une question non
non non pas du tout la cour de cassation
vient de renvoyer paul touvier devant
devant la justice et puisqu'il elle a
saisi la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de versailles
mais pour le seul massacre de
rillieux-la-pape d'une part et d'autre
part en refusant de se prononcer sur la
nature du régime de vichy
alors avant d'aller plus loin je
voudrais savoir ce que vous inspire
cette décision de la cour de cassation
d'abord un grand soulagement que savait
que la tradition c'est de ne pas
commenter si en justice s'ils restent il
ya ces traditions respectées donc vous
pouvez y aller oui parfois même et
parfois même il est heureux qu'elle
n'ait pas été respectée parce que je
crois que le mouvement d'opinion
qu'avait suscité le premier arrêt et non
lui à sans conséquence sur ce qui vient
de se passer c'est parce que la société
a bougé l'associât trouve inadmissible
le non lieu dont ou via bénéficier que
finalement celui ci a été au moins
partiellement cassé
donc c'est un grand soulagement de voir
que une des pages les plus noires les
plus indignes notre histoire se voient
sanctionnés par la justice et sans doute
l'instruction qui va être conduite sur
le massacre de rillieux la pape mettra
en lumière le rôle que chacun connaît
maintenant mais qu'il faut rappeler
parce que le souvenir de ce qui s'est
passé c'est quand même dans une certaine
mesure la garantie que cela ne revienne
pas rappeler donc comment la police
française a participé à son complice
mêmes soumises et parfois volontairement
soumises à ce que l'occupant nazi lui
demander et aggravante alors au chapitre
du souvenir beaucoup de vos amis
politiques se sont émus d'une attitude
du président de la république qui était
le dépôt de gerbe au maréchal pétain le
11 novembre dernier et ici même à votre
place henri emmanuelli a évoqué
différence de génération en gros entre
le président de la république est ce que
vous êtes parmi ceux qui avaient
ressenti cette différence de générations
entre entre eux et le président j'ai dit
dans les jours qui ont immédiatement
suivi que pour moi c'était peu
compréhensible que le pétain du vel
d'hiv avait effacé le peten verdun et
que par conséquent je ressentais pour
moi difficilement le fait que l'on
puisse d'une quelconque manière honorer
la mémoire de pétain depuis j'entends
une pause dans la république dira qu' il
allait prendre initiative
le premier ministre l'a confirmé hier
soir quel type d'initiative
souhaitez-vous vous même à moins que
vous n'ayez une idée de cette initiative
que vous étiez avec le président de la
république en israël oui non je n'ai
aucune idée de l'initiative qu'il entend
prendre et
je prends rapide fait que qu'il va qu'il
va la prendre je peux simplement dire
que pour moi à titre personnel je crois
que le nom de peta est indissolublement
liées aux massacres des populations
juives en france et que j'ai beaucoup de
mal à lui accorder un quelconque crédit
même si c'est le héros de verdun et par
rapport à ceux qui disent que la
république n'étaient pas concernés
puisque en effet la république s'est
arrêté avec l'état français elle n'a
repris qu'à la libération d'une
parenthèse dans l'art et voilà vous vous
considérez que ce n'est pas la
république est en question mais que la
france doit encore exactement c'est de
demander pardon peut-être comme on l'a
fait pour les victimes du sens qu'on
sait c'est une argutie juridique c'est
vrai que l'état français de peta est le
contraire de la république dans ses
valeurs dans ce qu'il voulait faire
il reste que c'est quand même la france
et que c'est quand même une tache sur la
france bien on va parler un peu
politique et que l'allemagne ne donne
des leçons d'ailleurs dans ce domaine là
on enchaîne le mari oui je ne vais pas
vous demander comment vous allez gagner
les élections ni même si vous allez
gagner je vais quand même vous dire je
vais m'amuser les d'abord faire une
remarque à fait parce que vous êtes
membre d'un gouvernement dont les
membres manifestement ne se bousculent
pas au portillon pour aller se battre
devant les électeurs donc pour aller
devant les électeurs rendre compte de
leurs de leurs de leurs actions écoutez
il y a dans un gouvernement des membres
qui sont des élus et d'autres qu'ils ne
sont pas je ne n'ai pas le temps et
chantelle je crois que tous ceux qui
sont des élus se représentent d'autres
qui viennent d'autres horizons n'ont pas
obligatoirement envie de se présenter
devant les électeurs fait qui trompe
c'est pas sa fille qui compte c'est
votre question vous n'avez pas voulu me
poser mais si vous permettez je vais
quand même y venir
c'est de savoir comment on va faire pour
gagner les élections alors aujourd'hui
il est clair que les sondages ne donnent
pas exactement cette indication là et
les meilleurs commentateurs que vous
êtes monsieur ne nous prédisent pas une
victoire éclatante
moi je crois quand même que quatre mois
de campagne ses quatre mois pendant
lesquels le beaucoup de choses peuvent
changer
et si je ne dirais pas aujourd'hui que
je suis sûr qu'on va gagner les
élections parce que vous prendriez pour
un doux rêveur je veux vous dire que si
on se bat si on se base sur ce qui a été
fait qu'on a un peu tendance quand même
à oublier
si on explique ce que les autres veulent
faire ce que la droite aujourd'hui l'a
pas beaucoup de programmes je suis très
frappé de voir qu'un an avant 86 y avait
eu des assises de l'opposition un
programme sera aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
me place silence personne ne dit rien
temps en temps tel ou tel dit quelque
chose mais n'y a pas de programme
officiel peut-être parce qu'ils veulent
pas trop
dire ceux qui voudraient faire quand on
aura expliquer rappeler aux français ce
que c'est que la droite au pouvoir ce
que c'est que la gauche au pouvoir
je suis convaincu que les résultats ne
seront pas s'il faut quand même dire ce
que vous préparez vous vous allez voir
techniquement sur vos adversaires
on va y venir et violine cosy avec laure
voilà alors l'avenir mais attendait
d'abord je voudrais savoir s'il vaut
mieux se battre pour gagner les
élections ce qui paraît en effet une
brève comme vous venez de le dire ou
bien s'il ne faut pas comme certains de
vos amis vous le suggère il ya ici à la
main qui a écrit dans une revue du parti
socialiste parts et messieurs par ts qui
ne vaut pas mieux prendre acte que la
cure d'opposition ça a du bon et qu à ce
stade de votre histoire vous avez besoin
d'une cure d'opposition
je crois que c'est une manière
intelligente de prendre le problème mais
qui n'est pas la manière d'un homme
politique
moi je ne me bats pas pour savoir s'il
vaut mieux que je dirais non pas que je
vais année je me bats pour défendre les
idées auxquelles je crois et je crois
d'ailleurs que c'est la meilleure
manière de gagner donc je défends décidé
je défends mon bilan
et si je gagne c'est que en effet les
électeurs ont reconnu qu'il vaut mieux
que je continuerai ce poids si je perds
enfin le tire les leçons de ce que les
électeurs auront décidé mais je crois
pas qu'il faille se poser la question à
l'avance de façon presque stratégique de
savoir s'il ne vaudrait pas mieux perdre
bien alors aujourd'hui on parle on parle
plus du ps on parle d'une alliance pour
le progrès mais pour faire une alliance
il faut être plusieurs alors vous allez
vous à lire qui l'alliance en question
comprend des partis ou des mouvements
politiques qui traditionnellement ont
été posées socialiste je pense faire
j'ai surtout aux écologistes que tout le
monde pense lorsqu'on évoque cette
alliance
alors faut-il s'allier aux écologistes
radicaux de gauche quand même d'accord
j'aime bien méprisant pour les radis que
je suis pas méprisants du tout mais je
constate que le leur ai dit claude vous
fournirons pas là points nécessaires là
le problème de l'alliance se pose avec
les écologistes vous êtes d'accord
et comment voyez-vous d'ailleurs ce
problème j'aime bien ce que disent les
écologistes
je crois qu'ils mettent le doigt sur des
problèmes qu'on a trop peu traitée on
sait tout le monde ceux ci bien à droite
que la gauche de ce point de vue là et
que on commence à prendre en compte de
façon de plus en plus active
l'industrie que je suis se préoccupe
beaucoup plus sans doute que mes
prédécesseurs je leur fais pas grief
crois que c'est l'évolution des temps de
ce que l'industrie française d'une
industrie moins polluantes de récupérer
les déchets on a mis en place des
structures pour ça bref ça bouge et sans
doute assez largement sous la pression
des écologistes mais ce que ça c'est la
partie positive mais ce que vous n'êtes
pas le moins bien placé pour parler aux
écologistes compte tenu du fait que vous
êtes un ministre qui a récemment donné
qu tort à son collègue de
l'environnement sur la sphère des
déchets australien et qui vient de
signer pour l' usine de la hague un
nouveau contrat de retraitement de
combustible en l'espèce du combustible
américain qui viendra s'ajouter au menu
on a signé aucun nouveau contrat on a
simplement traiter ce qui existait pour
ce qui est du problème précédent
je crois que vous avez raison de dire
que je suis un ministre qui est
particulièrement préoccupée des
questions d'environnement
prenons l'exemple du pyralène c'est ça
qui avait un peu secoué il n'a pas dit
exactement ça il a dit vous êtes
communiste qui a contré le ministère de
la ministre de l'environnement non mais
ça c'est un débat naturel au sein du
gouvernement chacun dans son rôle ce qui
est important c'est que la france qui
plus que d'autres pays est capable de
traiter des déchets doit le faire sinon
ces déchets il reste faut savoir
l'écologie est un problème mondial c'est
pas un problème franco français ça
s'arrête pas aux frontières
par conséquent si nous avons plus que
d'autres la capacité de faire des choses
ça serait criminel de ne pas le faire et
de laisser c'était le pyralène de
laisser ce pyralène tout seul à
l'extérieur il vaut mieux le retraité
c'est pourquoi j'ai insisté pour qu'on
autorise retraitement de ce pyralène en
france évidemment à terme il vaudra
mieux que ceux qui l'utilisent en
l'occurrence les australiens le trait de
chez eux
j'en suis tout à fait d'accord les
organisations écologistes ont raison de
ce point de vue là mais tant qu'ils sont
pas capables de faire chez eux
vaut mieux le faire chez nous que ne pas
le retraité du tout et en ce sens je
crois que la france est un pays qui a
des industries de l'environnement je
soutiens beaucoup et où on a organisé
des regroupements pour faire des géants
mondiaux de traitement des déchets du
jir mondiaux du traitement de l'eau à
des industries d'environnement donc
particulièrement puissante et donc cette
préoccupation que les écologistes la
partage totalement là où le problème
politique se pose c'est que je ne crois
pas que l'écologie c'est une réponse à
l'ensemble des questions que la
politique pose question nouvelle wii
l'ensemble des questions non par exemple
quand on se pose un problème sur le fait
de savoir si
il convient ou non que des forces
militaires interviennent en bosnie pour
séparer les serbes et bosniaques
on peut essayer de répondre à cette
question par tina lys politique mais on
ne peut pas y répondre à partir de
critères qui relève de l'écologie c'est
pourquoi si j'ai beaucoup de sympathie
pour ce que disent les écologistes je ne
crois pas que l'on puisse comme il le
souhaite même et je crois qu'ils se
trompent d'ailleurs pour ça que je ne
suis pas écolo ziis je crois pas qu'on
puisse comme il le souhaite même dire
que c'est une explication générale et
que donc ils vont remplacer les forces
piliers dont on a mûri ce que vous
croyez en à un accord politique en bonne
et due forme entre votre formation le
parti socialiste et les écologistes ou
bien est-ce que vous pensez que chacun
ira à la bataille séparément et que dans
votre circonscription vous vous
retrouverez face à peut-être au maintien
d'un candidat écologiste tous nous
allons nous allons avoir ce test là de
nombreux électeurs écologistes sont des
électeurs qui ont été les électeurs de
gauche voire des électeurs du parti
socialiste il se présente la plupart des
écologistes pas tous la plupart comme
des hommes et des femmes de progrès qui
veulent le changement de la du monde
dans lequel ils vivent qu'ils veulent le
progrès comme nous le souhaitons pas où
ils attendent tous préoccupés des mêmes
problèmes mais allant dans le même sens
alors on va bien voir justement
et si en effet ils sont sur les
positions qu'ils annoncent alors je ne
doute pas que d'une manière ou d'une
autre
ensemble nous trouverons des modalités
notamment au second tour des élections
pour que nous fassions barrage à quelque
chose que nous combattons qui est le
conservatisme parce que en dépit de ce
que disait françois henri de virieu dans
sa présentation tout à l'heure que je
n'ai pas voulu interrompre il ya une
certaine farce avoir un stand d'homme de
droite se présenter aujourd'hui comme
les tenants de la réforme même les
producteurs de lait on y vient justement
de ce que je voulais revenir en la
présentation françois-henri tout à
l'heure et reprendre très exactement la
distinction qu'il faisait il disait tout
à l'heure la morale elle s'est perdue la
réforme
aujourd'hui c'est balladur et la juge
l'aspiration à la justice sociale elle
est portée par pasqua séguin donc
question centrale qu'est ce qui vous
reste pour affirmer une identité de
gauche
mais avant que vous ne répondez à cette
question qui me paraît essentiel je
voudrais revenir d'un mot sur la morale
quand vous apprenez par la presse qu'une
information est ouverte que quelqu'un
est inculpé qui a été directeur de
cabinet d'un ministre et qu'il s'agit du
point de savoir s'il y a
ou non commission sur l'attribution de
scanners pour les hôpitaux comment vous
réagissez
qu'est-ce que vous est-ce que vous vous
sentez un jeu c'est pas un minimum
solidaires de ceux qui ont je réagis
d'abord en neuf évitant toute réaction
sans savoir ce qu'il y assure en effet
c'est à dire je ne sais pas si ces faits
sont vrais ou pas il suffit pas qu'à
monsieur en l'occurrence monsieur trajet
redisent des choses pour qu'on accepte
pour argent comptant
comme il ne suffit pas que monsieur
balladur écrivain cher de la réforme
pour qu'il soit réformateur bon si en
revanche la justice qui se saisit du
dossier prouve qu'il ya eu des
malversations alors je me sentirai
évidemment pas solidaires de ceux qui
ont fait ces malversations
mais pour le moment je vois beaucoup
d'inculpation est pas encore beaucoup de
preuves apportées donc je suis réservé
bien donc venons en à la réforme et à la
justice sociale
portés par d'autres qu'est ce qui vous
reste aujourd'hui pour affirmer pour
vous différencier pour affirmer une
identité de gauche
et qu'est ce que c'est aujourd'hui
qu'une identité forte vis-à-vis de
l'opinion je veux dire c'est pas une
sorte de jugement sur pasqua écrit un
texte sous l'avant une politique sociale
que pour autant il a récupéré tout ce
qui est l'idéologie sociale dans ce pays
tu est une farce de dire ça quand depuis
dix ans c'est peut-être parce que vous
avez laissé le terrain social libre
nous l'avons pas le lui de la réforme ou
la laisser en jachère
alors nous n'avons pas laissé libre mais
surtout pas rentrer ou pas fait assez ça
je suis assez d'accord avec vous mais
quand depuis dix ans toutes les lois
sociales qu'il s'agisse de la retraite à
60 ans qui s'est déjà cinquième semaine
de congés payés qui sèche de lys gf la
peau ces grandes fortunes ex-agent du
rmi pour éviter les exclusions toutes
ces lois bien d'autres encore ont vu la
droite voté contre
est ce qu'on peut dire que après avoir
été contre boue pendant 12 ans toutes
les réformes qui allaient dans le sens
d'une amélioration
les problèmes sociaux dans ce pays on
est aujourd'hui légitime pour être ceux
qui prônent la réforme et ceux qui
disent nous avons réglé c'est votre
jugement sur la droite ses voeux
l'opposition donc on comprend que vous
portiez ce jugement mais vous même
qu'est ce qui va vous distinguer en quoi
est-ce que vous êtes porteur d'une
identité dit de gauche et qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
quand dans un pays on dit il faut
d'abord gagner de l'argent et puis
ensuite on distribuera ce qui a en
excédent à ceux qui en ont besoin
on défend assez largement je crois une
orgie de droite mais quand on dit pour
que ce pays soit capable de mieux se
battre de gagner de l'argent souvent que
les entreprises vivent
il faut que l'on tienne compte en amont
des primes de participation des
individus de cohésion sociale on défend
alors je crois une des régies de gauche
et si cette différence la demeure et
elle demeure alors il n'y a pas de
confusion entre la gauche à droite moi
je constate aujourd'hui que les pays
dans lesquels cette cohésion sociale
existe dans l'entreprise ou dans le pays
c'est vrai au japon c'est vrai en
allemagne sur les pays qui s'en sortent
le mieux
etc l inverse les pays ça a été les
états unis reagan ça et l angleterre de
l'âme cette chère dans lequel on faisait
fi de la cohésion sociale on disait ça
viendra de surcroît après quand on aura
résolu de problèmes sur les pays qui se
sont enfoncés est ce qu'on sait que
depuis le début des années 60
nous étions à peu près à égalité le
pouvoir d'achat entre la france et
l'angleterre a évolué de 20 % de
différence ou sommes 20% au-dessus ce
soit parce que nous sommes un pays dans
lequel on a toujours plus mis l'accent
sur la cohésion sociale et ça c'est
l'idéologie de gauche
moi je crois que tout ce que nous
pouvons faire nous devons le faire et
tout ce que nous pouvons faire en ce
domaine là c'est justement d'aller plus
loin que nous l'avons fait pendant les
dix ans et on peut nous reprocher pas
avoir été assez loi j'accepte très
volontiers ses critiques elle est vraie
nous devons aller plus loin tout ce qui
fonde cette cohésion sociale c'est pour
ça que je parlais des banlieues tout à
l'heure à ce stade il me reste une
question à ce stade de l'histoire des
socialistes et c est ce qu il n'est pas
temps de mettre la clé sous la porte et
de changer les choses de fermer le parti
socialiste est de faire autre chose
est-ce que vous
dans quel camp vous rangez vous dans ce
qu'ils considèrent que quelques
amendements à la situation du ps
suffiront où est-ce qu'il faut remettre
les choses à plat et repartir autrement
puis je m'intéresse à la politique
j'ai vu la droite prendre le nom de rpf
de nerfs du dr y aussi le p r puis lcds
maintenant il ya l'upm tout ça ce sont
des habits d'art le cas pour cacher la
même chose
le ps lui a gardé son unité mais ça
change rien au fond il ya d'un côté les
positions sur les positions de droite de
l'autre côté qui sont des positions de
gauche la différence entre les deux
chacun la sens bien et moi je devais à
dire d'un mot ça serait bien sûr cet
accent mis sur la cohésion sociale et
sur la solidarité est l'outil dont on se
sert l'outil politique le parti
politique pour pouvoir mettre ça en
oeuvre importe peu ce qui compte c'est
d'avoir bien clair en tête ce que sont
les objectifs politiques voilà c'était
l'heure de vérité de monsieur dominique
strauss kahn ministre de l'industrie et
du commerce extérieur
[Musique]